it is mind-blowing to me how you grew up
and how you grew up and you're still
sane you know that you didn't i'm like
okay now
are you okay i mean your mother and
father
in fact lied to you your whole life you
know at two years old your parents
divorce
your mother remarries and she presents
to you that the guy she remarried is
your real father your biological father
and then the additional pain you find
out that your real father was alive that
he was a guy who used to visit the
family as a family friend
did you ever say to your mother mom why
didn't you tell me my biological father
was my biological father
well i think i had to come to terms with
most of that stuff if not
all of it pretty quickly for one reason
i was
uh young and since then i i feel like
you know my mom and i have just a great
great relationship and
eddie eddie are you saying that you've
forgiven your mother
for not telling you that your biological
father was your biological father and
why would your biological father go
along with that
it's something i can't comprehend i had
three younger brothers and
were extremely extremely close and and
this is
1969 or something right
and their logic was we
want them to feel like brothers and they
don't we don't want them to feel
separated and like step brothers and
you know nowadays it's much different
nowadays you have single moms raising
kids it's not a it's not a social pariah
your name was ed mueller growing up
right yeah mueller
eddie mueller and this guy mueller
becomes your father
he treated you poorly was he physically
abusive or was he just
a a mentally abusive guy oh wow i can't
you know i i want to say like i was
probably a little bit of a
out of control teenager but but you know
my
my parents were splitting up and
uh i was upset about that my mom took my
brothers to chicago
i stayed in california i was like
working at the long's drugs and
um eddie that's amazing i mean at 15
you're living on your own you're going
to school and you're working to support
yourself
the famous story was you went to your
teachers and the teachers were
complaining about your grades and you
said you opened up your backpack and you
showed them
your bills yeah mr moreno said you know
you missed another test this is reality
and i spilled out my bills i said no sir
this is my reality but you laugh about
it
but i mean that is so sweet because it
all worked out so well
you know i know what it's like to be
under the lion's paw had i not been
through any of that
you know i'd i'd you know my whole life
would be a sham
but let me just clarify one last thing
when my mom
told me that this guy wasn't my father
and it was somebody else
you know that was it was a shock
but i was i was so grateful in a way
i mean i was like oh [ __ ] like
thank god you know because i really
didn't i didn't come out of this guy's
balls
i mean uh i don't have any genetic
relation to this guy
you know there's a line in in tommy it's
the who and and
and and roger's tommy is singing to the
crowd and he says uh hey you
uh mr normal you know that was the guy i
didn't want to be
i didn't want to be mr normal and
kind of the way i was brought up i was
worried about just like being mr normal
and so even when my mom told me that you
know
my dad wasn't my dad i thought well
that's a that's a [ __ ]
interesting twist like my life got
way more interesting at that moment
you know
you